the Joe Rogan experience the good thing
is is that you know that's sort of
mature thinking you have about not one
to [ __ ] up your life I'm starting every
day I get more and more to thinking that
way mmm so it's improving still yeah
even though you're nine months in it's a
constant it's so that's like - like
endurance like you're strengthening your
endurance your resolve mentally more
than anything
yeah well that's it's almost all mental
at this point it is yeah at this point
it is you know you just gotta have again
something spared me and I'm 52 and I
would love my legacy to be someone that
helped people but you know even what you
already have whether you realize it or
not and I guarantee you if you keep
going you will I hope so you know it's a
hundred percent if you keep going with
these stories with your your personality
and your sense of humor this is a
hundred percent gonna help people and
not just a few and [ __ ] millions of
people you know Robert Downey jr. III
when the paperback version of my first
book came out I wrote a paragraph about
him to where you know again about the
the ruthlessness of show business people
say show business is very forgiving well
if you're that talented of an actor like
Robert Downey jr. they let you come back
and through his assistant he contacted
me and um was so was so nice like you
know and I got at this point he was Iron
Man you know and um he you know and I'm
this comedian he's a big star fan he had
read the book and he appreciated that I
thought I was complementing to him in
the book and again there's an example to
12-step stuff he really was like he goes
I'm through he said basically to me I'm
here for you if you need me I'm here for
you Joe Walsh me Eagles who I met
through the star know same thing hmm
that's amazing
you know it like like these guys are
like because it it helps them it helps
everybody so so Robert Downey helped me
in a way just by knowing that he got
better could you talk about chaos his
life was I remember talking about him on
the start show when he got sound you
know the stripper with the Wonder Woman
outfit and Krishna stripper dressed like
Wonder Woman and crystal meth in
somebody else's house but I've always
wondered like a guy like that that's so
[ __ ] talented
he's talented in this weird explosive
sort of creepy he's unique he's unique
guy if you watch his movies even though
he's in a [ __ ] movie he's great yeah
like he always look at what he's doing
he makes unique choices as an actor but
I've always wondered if like the engine
behind that is the same engine of
addiction absolutely whole Civ wild
reckless sort of energy and now he just
contains it in progress and success like
this time working I mean I don't know
him personally just just through that
contact I just told you about but it
seems like he's like way into the
program of AAA right I know yeah I mean
again it's also like the premise of
going through a meeting an NA meeting I
try to go to five or six a week now and
that's that even you know they want you
to go to 1990 there's a lot of comedians
in recovery you know I won't mention who
they are but you know it's an anonymous
thing but there's so many guys where 20
years ago there was a stigma attached to
and there's not anymore I think people
understand now it's not being weak be
pleased to think it's a week it's like
it's these are behavior patterns their
thought patterns and you get stuck in a
rut of them and you get there's a smooth
carved path that your behavior two
slides or it in and goes and it's hard
to hit those [ __ ] breaks and stop
that path yeah and you use the behaviors
to manipulate like if you have a talent
like a sense of humor you know it's
funny I one of my POS said to me you're
gonna tell me you never used your sense
of humor to obtain drugs I go I don't
know what drug dealers you know but as
payment like listen noodles I want that
ounce of cocaine I have no cash but
knock knock he's not gonna work you use
a sense of humor to get the money to buy
directly what what what the people at
the task evaluators a drug court a lot
of these these rehabs do is they link
exactly what you just said they link
every behavior back to yeah the drug use
yeah like what why why acting this way
why being charming if you can charming
you can't be charming sometimes is rabia
yeah
[Applause]